hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie today we're going to
continue on with what we were doing last
week and that's adding routes and
components to our react site and we're
gonna be creating some more graph QL
queries so a lot of the same stuff we'll
have we'll have a lot of new content so
I've been working on migrating some
content over so I think I have maybe
like four new custom post types and a
couple of new taxonomy so I'll try to do
front-end work on the stream and then do
the data migration stuff on my own and
that way we'll always have new new
content to try to set up on the on the
front end side of things so I hope
everyone had a good weekend and hey I
see on the live chat I
I was recently doing some reading about
OBS which is what I used to stream and
I've changed the settings and I managed
to get the CPU usage down I think like
by a third so let me know if the video
quality seems ok I don't want to drop
everything down too much I should still
get 1080p and we shouldn't have any
issues with stuttering and or dropping
frames or anything so hopefully it all
works out right but so far it looks like
this is this would be the right setting
alright so let me let me switch over to
show my screen
okay let's move this down a bit and
increase the size here all right so just
a refresher and also if you're new to
the stream I break the stream up into
25-minute segments and I'll try to do
some coding for 25 minutes and then I
will take a 5-minute break go to the
live chat answer as many questions as I
can and that five-minute break and then
we'll do some more code and then at the
very end I answer all the questions in
the live chat so the streams usually
aren't longer than two hours sometimes
there are only about an hour but if you
if you do ask a question please be
patient and I will get to it
eventually if you can't stick around you
can always check out the recording all
the recordings of these streams are
available on the free code camp YouTube
channel alright cool it looks like you
all have noticed that the fans aren't
running yeah it's really quiet in here
nah it's amazing it's like I never
really noticed how noisy it was until
till now I can hear the fans at all it's
that's pretty well all right so
hopefully the audio is a little better
for you all as well and I really I
didn't even realize it was that bad okay
so today let me
alright let me give you trying to figure
out where we left off so we left off
with Department pages it looks like so
here's basically kind of what we've been
doing in case you haven't seen the
streams or you missed some we create new
pages right so we're using reacts and in
particular we're using next Jas and next
has its own routing system but we're
kind of you know adding our own routing
on top of that so within this pages
folder we'll create a new page and then
we'll also create a new query for graph
QL and we'll create a new route in our
server j/s file and once we complete
that process then there'll be a whole
new section of the site that'll be
available to pooling content so we've
already completed that for several
sections so we have a section for
faculty member as a section for academic
majors we also have a section for
academic departments so we're going to
continue on today and some of the things
that I brought in since then are we have
associate's degrees which I don't think
I'm finished bringing all the data so we
might skip that as well as minors and we
have Institute's and organization I
think it's Institute's and organizations
I just shortened it to Institute's for
API purposes and then we have some staff
members
I also brought in a bunch of videos as a
custom post type but I can't really do
anything with those yet I'm gonna need
someone to go in manually and sort
through those and then assign them to a
category so that we can pull them in to
places where we need them so basically
that's just like in a YouTube embed tag
inside a wordpress custom post site
all right so let's pull in let's see
let's go with miners for now yeah let's
go with miners so the first thing that I
want to do is I want to go to the
current website and I want to check what
the URL is because we need to match that
with our route wherever possible we're
going to keep URLs from the old URL to
the new one which I probably should
mention for those of you who are new
we're taking an old website for the
University the main University website
here at Franciscan University and we're
making a pletely new website but we need
to migrate the content and we want to
keep the URLs the same wherever possible
all right obviously because I'm sure
there's a lot of inbound links and
things that will break if we mess up the
URL structure obviously will not be good
for SEO as well because I'm sure will
still show up in a lot of search results
for URLs that are now broken and then as
soon as the search engine realizes that
we will drop out of the search results
so it's very important that we
double-check these oops wrong side area
see how long it takes today to load so
from the load times alone it should be
obvious why we need to build a new
website Wow and this website is actually
hosted on campus so it's just maybe I
don't know less maybe like less than a
mile maybe a kilometre I'm less probably
less than where I am right now it's
insane that it takes that long to get
here
okay so we need to find our miners
undergraduate another thing that I'd
like to do if possible is kind of you
figure out where people are going the
most and where people want to go based
on analytics and then make those
sections very easy to get to so we
should have a section for miners there
we are
so let's check out our miner programs
and see hopefully we have some
consistency with the URLs if not we may
have to you know take another oh it
looks like Wow
hmmm alright this is gonna be tough so
it's probably hard for you all to see
what the URL is just word because
they're so small
let me alright I see they are asking for
end rock I already started the server I
just forgot to paste it so here's the
here's the link for the end rock server
um you can click that and check out the
site as we as we make it
world's s what is is this what people
call migrations migration I mean we're
that we're migrating data we're moving
the yeah I mean I guess we're we're
migrating we have to migrate the data
from one database to another so that we
can use a different content management
system oh goodness
okay so let me explain to you what is
that stuff about these URLs right now so
here's all our miners like Legal Studies
for instance is just Franciscan ddu
slash Legal Studies but then classical
Latin is Franciscan dot edu slash
classics slash classical Latin so
there's not really consistency this one
is kind of the odd one out because it's
formatted like this all the other ones
are formatted based on the the
department or the the major program it's
it's probably the department on that so
Franciscan Studies is just Franciscan
dot edu slash Franciscan Studies all
right this is going to be more difficult
so I guess here's what we'll need to do
for the ones that are
just straight-up like dot edu slash
something we're gonna have to create are
their own routes to keep the URL the
same but then we're gonna need to I
don't know we're going to need to figure
out an alternate route so we want to
keep the old URLs but then within the
site we want to keep things really
logical and clean so I'm going to need
your help
just thinking through this would it be
more logical to make all the miners have
let's say Franciscan ddu slash minor
slash final classical Latin or whatever
or would it make more sense to have it
Franciscan edu slash classics which
would be the department name slash
classical Latin let me know if that
question even makes sense at all to you
and then let me know what you think this
yeah it's kind of wondering so think we
do we are making the majors let's look
at our router for a second oops or yet
our server Jas file here right now what
we have going on is yeah so we have like
these kind of routes for our majors but
then we're also making a route and this
will be kind of our new structure that
we're going to encourage is major slash
and then the ID for the major
okay it looks like a few years saying to
do Department slash program is a better
way to do things
okay okay let's go let me go back here
and and let's see classic straight minor
okay the the slug actually with some of
them already says minor in it I think
that's not a bad idea to keep it to keep
the name of minor in there so just I
just want to double check and make sure
that these are linking to pages that's
just for the minor okay good so film
studies minor okay
Stephen says I can't get the end
Rockside open is anyone else having
trouble with the edgar oxide let's see
jeff said it opened on his phone but not
on the workstation it could be the
firewall all right let me know what's
going on with that you try to copy and
paste the link as well because sometimes
links with with YouTube are are weird
like in the live chat
okay all right so I'm gonna take one
last check at all these suggestions
before we actually create the route
Michaels say we could do Department and
then program and then major or minor
okay maybe we could
yeah maybe we could do that let me let's
see XS biology department call Martha
theology classes gospel sighs all right
yes so these are already categorized
under Department I suppose so for now
let's go with slash department slash and
then we'll put the name of the the
program the name of the minor okay yeah
we'll do it like that
and that will actually match up with the
current way of doing things so that's
okay for some of them will have to
account for the the current URL and then
also direct things into the new system
okay there's also may be some changes
restructuring like departments and
things so I don't think any of those
changes will happen before the site
launches but I guess it wouldn't it
would be almost a little bit of a waste
I suppose overthink this because it it's
likely that it may change at some point
this year all right like I don't know
anything for sure but I've just heard
that's a possibility so we may have a
different organization I I would hate I
really wish that I could know for sure
how that's gonna play out before we made
these because it could mess up the
organization of all the academic stuff
on the site but oh well we'll do what we
need to do for now okay so let's go to
our code and let's try to set up some
routes here so I'm gonna grab this for
now
let's see Department Department was
okay I see now what I was trying to do
and I just never finish that okay
so what we'll need is
actually I'm not sure I'm gonna do this
all right let me let me think through
this with y'all so basically we need a
double parameterised route so we would
need something like IV one you know so
they're basically like the department
and then you know the ID for the minor
but here's the problem with that we have
you know this isn't the only place where
we have this type of thing happening
all right let me know if if anybody
first like if you see the issue - or if
I'm just like missing something big here
let me think about this for a second
all right I think I think we need to go
back and just do do it like this and now
it makes more sense why I did this with
the major because I think that's really
our only our only option so yeah there's
just not I just don't know of a way to
do kind of like a double variable here
and to have that work out essentially
because we're we're units we're dealing
with a lot of different custom post
types it's like right now a lot of our
pages we're directing these two are very
very similar but they're not always
gonna be similar they can have different
things so it's like what would I direct
this to what I have to keep on a list of
all the different names of the
departments so it's if one of these
names is the department and then if one
of these names is a minor then we send
it to the minor route so I I don't know
I think this will be it whether or not
this is the ideal URL I think this is
really our only logical option at this
point and I don't think it's for one
thing it will keep our URL shorter yeah
we're just gonna we're gonna have to
really try to make sure that all our
URLs can fit in in this type of thing
where we just have like the descriptor
like category and then we have you know
with the the variable the parameterised
route would be I think we can do that
let's see Michael says the issue is that
whoever initially set up the site didn't
make a standard and have everyone stick
to it yeah I mean that's that's kind of
like what happened part of the issue too
I think is at I don't know the full
history and I didn't work with this site
that much but there was some
functionality that the site was supposed
to have that and didn't have and then
various things just quit working during
the time the site was there so some
things were done that wasn't really part
of the plan but it had to be done just
to get pages up and I think that's part
of the reason why there's so much
weirdness also I know there's been a lot
of different people working on it
student workers and things like that so
it hasn't been hasn't been one person
working on it and that I guess there
hasn't really been enforcement of a
strict standard for things it's possible
that reorganization has happened as well
like maybe some things are categorized
used to be categorized differently I
don't know Nick says do you need
something like a nested resource like
slash Department slash department ID / -
such minor ID yeah
yeah actually would that work all right
let me paste this in and see what y'all
think I think it's gonna end up making
really long URLs but you all let me know
if you think it would be better so what
if we had instead of miner ID we would
have department and then whatever the
department name is and then miner and
whatever the miner name is that might
work I'm not sure we could try it but
I'm not even gonna try it if you think
that's gonna end up getting ridiculous
all right how few of you kind of came in
and said hello hey everybody that just
came in all right I'm gonna give
everybody just a few seconds to think
about that and let me know hmm let me
just put it in here for now and comment
it out because even if we don't use it
right now I do I like that we that
that's a possibility if we end up
finding a case where we have to do
something like that
what the exes trailing space is not
there yeah okay all right in any case
what we can do right now is we can make
a component and we can make our graph QL
query
Michael Creole says can't you override
the actual URL in the route I'm not I'm
not exactly sure what you're referring
to the the thing is so I need wait
wait Michael and you just reminded me so
the issue is I need to be able to grab
the URL as it currently is in direct it
to the right place and if I can't do
that then we're just gonna we're gonna
have to break the urls and we can't
anything about it so essentially I need
to be able to do this where it's like I
need to be able to do this and then I
also need to be able to just grab I mean
I could always there's not that many
miners so potentially I could just hard
code what's in there
I hate to do that but I I'm gonna end up
with so many things hard-coded I don't
really see any way around it especially
when we don't have consistency with with
URLs film studies
so this like I'm gonna have to have like
stuff like this
Jeff says try utilizing the web server
to do the rewrite for the incoming
request I mean I could well I think
we're still going to have the same thing
though is I'm gonna have to have a ton
of rewrites so I mean whether it's here
or whether it's in the web server which
will be but we're going to use nginx
reverse proxies so either way we're just
gonna have to have a list all right
all right so here's what I'm gonna do so
I will have this minor and then our ID
and then that is gonna send it to the
component that's minor but it will also
have this sort of thing it's gonna send
that to the component that's minor but
then we're going to manually give it the
ID of film studies well as a string
justice I would put the rewrite rules at
the web server side keeps this code
cleaner or says maybe do those using a
loop to save some time we could how
about all right so here's what I think
about that one yes I'm definitely open
to cleaning this up somehow loops or
whatever to clean things up or
potentially like we probably should do
at the very least is just get this stuff
out of here and put it in a separate
file I'm also open to redoing this in
for like nginx
for now though I'm gonna do them here
just so that I can see what I'm working
with and then that way they'll at least
be in a place so that later on I won't
forget what I was trying to do so as
long as we have one example or at least
one example for each type of URL that's
currently being used on the site that
should be enough we don't have to type
them all out right now we just need to
have one example make sure it works and
then we can move on to the next type hey
everybody I have a few people saying hi
coming in
Dinn antonio del let and in a hey how's
it going
alright so alright let's move forward so
I think the suggestions are good and I
think we should do them for right now
though I'm gonna do it like this and
then once we get a better idea of the
scale of everything then that should
give us a better idea of like what would
be the best way to clean this whole
thing off and to do it differently so
for now that's what I'm going to do I'm
just gonna try to comment things and
make it obvious what what these things
are so that when we come back we can
easily see like all the the groups here
alright so we have that route in there
we need a component new file miner
it's really possible that some of these
like major and minor really don't need
their own post types okay so this is
actually I mean this component is done
for now assuming that we're getting
similar content that we do for majors
that's done so if you want to check more
of this out about what's going on
check out the repo the links available
in in the description in this video and
now we'll go to the queries we're going
to make a new file I want to say minor
dot is as a query and we can grab the
major query and we're going to do the
same thing here whoops did not copy that
copy
this area and so now let's change this
minor and then mine is where name ID
contents like okay wonderful
alright so now we have our query what
did I do
I don't know what I did there
and I messed it up don't say that put it
there
say that major one needs to be deleted
okay to make sure I didn't mess that one
up that looks good
okay so let me try this so we should be
able to go to minor and then actually I
need to see what the slugs are for these
let's see what's our slug okay
I don't think I restarted the server and
I also don't remember exactly okay we
did say minor okay
let's restart this
area okay cool so we have Greek minor
classics Department little text here
some of the courses wonderful okay cool
so our data is being brought in properly
from our content management system which
is WordPress we wrote a graph QL query
that's bringing in the data that we need
and then we're displaying it with our
react component here on this site okay
looks good I mean it looks it looks
adequate right it's super playing right
now um but in terms of being able to
pull the data that's good okay okay let
me check two things one I never took my
timer so I never started my timer so let
me just check the time oh yeah I'm
definitely due to go back to the live
chat here alright so let me go to the
live chat right now then the second
thing I was gonna say is let me check
the live chat so I'm gonna go to the
live chat let me take I am gonna start
my timer now and I'm gonna put it on
five minutes and go through as much as I
can on the lodge
yeah ruins here berlin says finally
joined after so long yeah I haven't seen
you around for a while is everything
going
world's asked is n grukk is the end
group website the new website you're
rerouting to the end and rocket just
yeah that's just a way for you to open
the site on your machine and see what
we're doing as we're doing it I mean you
could go navigate wherever you want on
the site inspect it and dev tools when I
change something then automatically we
change for you as well
I'm so I'm scrolling through looking for
a question there's a lot of comments
about our routing options
alright so Michaels saying the loops
don't scale well make an array and then
do index of of the array okay that with
harsh says with loops only seven to
eight lines can do the thing Nikki's
here hey how's it going
it says hey everyone just got back from
physio and English I think I'm not sure
you should I say like your normal like
doctor's appointment stuff I think
anyway welcome welcome back
this person's handle in YouTube is
display:block I like that
it says hello what time do you study to
reach this level of coding I have been I
mean I've been doing this for like five
years
sorry no I just got so drowsy all of a
sudden yes so I you know it's so hard to
estimate really it just depends on your
situation like how many hours a day can
you study you know how good are you are
retaining new information you know what
your background is before that there's
just so much so it's going to be
different for everyone
I would say though if you're just
getting into coding like don't expect to
be able to do everything in a few weeks
right don't don't get discouraged that's
unrealistic expectations so you know
don't think it's going to take you years
and years to get you know good enough to
build anything meaningful you know but
at the same time you'll be realistic so
I guess there's like two two different
places you don't really want to be at
you don't want to be you know thinking
that you're going to learn everything
really fast and then get disappointed
when it doesn't happen and then you also
don't want to
be thinking that there's no way you'll
ever be able to do it right so be
realistic with I mean III see both
things with like you know people that
ask me questions is you know some some
people expect like I'm gonna be able to
do everything right away and then some
people are like you know I've only been
coding for you know so many months
there's no way anybody who ever hire me
right I don't think either one is really
true so just kind of you know be
realistic about that but in terms your
specific question I it's it's really
nearly impossible to give a timeline for
how long it would take to get to a
certain point
all right harsh it's giving some
examples of things that I could do to
clean up that code for all the routes so
thank you for that
mmm-hmm no life says hi how are you not
bad not bad are you doing
I only have just a few more things in
the live chat so even though my timer
off I'm gonna answer a few just so I can
get everything in here before you start
up with coding again the the lathe says
do you have against lint setup and in
that case which rule setup do you use we
follow standard jazz I think we're using
that's what we usually use for the prod
project so the standard J estriol Andrew
says how do you get started on big
projects like this I'm looking to get
into react how do I get started
I don't we just you start like you start
every project and you just keep you
break it down into small chunks and then
just keep going every day and getting
things done that's that's about it
Stephen says Jessie how often do you use
loops like four if 4-h and your job
please
use loops a lot sometimes I don't use
like a for loop as much and I'll try to
use like a dot map or something like
that or a filter or sort if I can I like
using this better Stephen says I'm
spending a lot like a lot on JavaScript
loops and I worry that I won't use it to
the level that I'm working with it
yeah a the being able to do loops and
having that concept out I mean it it's
important you will probably use loops or
something like a loop frequently
Stephens asking about dot map yeah I I
really do think dot map is easier to
write it I don't know like for
I really thought map is easier to reason
about I mean when you could see like a
for loop like you can see the how it's
going to increment in things so I don't
know it it might be easier to see how
it's how it's gonna work
but once you get familiar with map and
like filter things like that I do think
it's easier all right Nikki says those
array helpers are all things you can do
with a basic for loop they are just
written shorter your understanding of
the basic for loop will surely help yeah
I agree
I completely agree that's a good answer
all right last question then we go back
to the code and it says how often do you
visit the gym I actually have some
workout equipment in my basement at home
so I just do that I haven't been to like
an actual gym and maybe it's been over a
year I think it's yeah it's definitely
been over a year so I have I have an
exercise bike I have like a bench you
know bench press some weights and like
free weights and things so I could do
like a full body workout so not quite as
as nice as having like all the different
options that you have at a gym but it's
definitely convenient to be able to just
you know roll out of it and go right
into right into a workout so for now I
really like that I mean it I can
actually get into there's a gym on
campus here where I work so it's it's
pretty nice they have you know all just
standard stuff you'd see in any gym and
it was like Rach I used to go and play
racquetball before work with a co-worker
of mine but then I hurt my wrist so now
I'm like I don't really think that's a
good idea for me to do but anyway so I
don't really go to the gym but I've been
working out every morning for the last
two weeks so today officially is is two
weeks so I'm really proud of that before
that I hadn't worked out for a really
long time it was just really sporadic
like I work out maybe a few times a
month here and there but anyway let me
go back to the code and alright so we
basically proven the concept here works
and it works with our new route let's
make sure that we can also make it work
with have so like the old route will
still work all right Siena says that
that is nice keep training thanks I
appreciate that I'm like I'm scared
though that if I miss my workout once
like it's just gonna throw me off so I'm
really like I'm a Johnny go to bed super
early so I know I can wake up and
workout I mean I know what's gonna
happen eventually I probably I can't
keep this up forever but for right now I
just want to build that habit I want to
keep it up for like at least a month and
then hopefully it's enough of a habit
that I won't you know be easily you know
thrown off all right I'm gonna copy this
route and paste it in just to test and
make sure that this works and see film
studies often double check to make sure
that that's the right slug so if this
doesn't work I'll check that
all right yeah it's not the race look
let's let me go back here I have way
press open on my other screen so I can
check the routes film studies it's just
like film studies minor height said this
what is film studies minor and I'll
probably need to restart this
yeah yeah okay yeah so that works so we
can use calm arts film studies and that
should work for us and then we should
also be able to do minor slash
film studies minor alright great now
what we can do at some point is clean up
those slugs and WordPress so that it
doesn't say minor on the end if we don't
want it so we don't actually have to you
know have minor here and then minor at
the end because that's a little
redundant I don't think we need that
so that can that's something though that
I could have someone else do even if
they don't know about coding I could
just you know give them some
instructions and say go through all of
them and do it like this so I'm not
going to do it right now let's see all
right so let's go into
let's check out a another post date okay
you know what I do I want to do this
so let me
all right
here's what I'm gonna do
and I grabbed this because this is gonna
be almost exactly what I want to do for
these programs okay so whenever just
associate degree programs and right now
let's check this out and go to associate
degree program so our URL then is let's
see what our URL is gonna be waiting
waiting okay
oh goodness academics ug associate are
there really no links for these programs
oh they just have them within here but
this is a
all right so these links are also not in
standard alright and there's not a
separate page for this associate's
degree it just links you to the main
accounting page so there may not even be
separate pages for Associates programs
yeah there's no separate pages okay
here we are here's a separate page for
an associate's program
so we may we may only have one actual
page for associate programs fool okay
these these routes are going to be the
hardest part of this whole thing I think
okay so we'll do for the associate
degree programs for now I mean it's I'm
just gonna leave this as associate and
we're gonna have this as associate but
we may not even need this if there's
really only one page I I don't know if
it's worth it although I may we may
think about like okay well shouldn't we
have a separate page for each associate
program so I'll have to talk I don't
handle content and I don't really want
to handle the content so I also talked
to my boss about that and see what he
thinks for that that might be something
that gets added in so I'm gonna leave it
in here for now and then up here let's
say we're gonna say associate here and
then I want to take this to the
associate page as well and then I want
to give it the ID of let's give the idea
of main so I I was been thinking about
how to do this and one way so we have a
situation where we'll have let's say
here like department so the slash
department I want to just have a list of
all the different department pages so
then when you go a slash department
slash ID you can get to those pages so
my original thought was okay I'll have
it say when it's slash department I'll
send it to an entirely different
component right meaning Department lists
which will work but let's say the
components are close enough that we
don't really need two components so I
thought why not try it like this and
just manually pass in the ID main and
then make sure to say okay if the ID is
main then do this and then we'll make
the slug
in WordPress match so we'll make the
slug say main being the main page so I
want to try both different ways just to
see maybe if there's some issue that I'm
not seeing but this way will cut down on
the number of components that we need to
make and like I said as long as the
components are going to be very similar
then this works if we need minor changes
between you know how one of these pages
display versus the main page we can work
that out within a component if it's
major changes then it might make more
sense that two different components but
right now let's let's test this out so
let's save that I'm gonna go into
WordPress here and I guess I could do
this over here so everyone can see so
I've just gone in this associate
academic programs text which is right
now the only piece of data that we have
in here and I click so that to make the
slug visible and I'm gonna make this
love main which should be fine and won't
mess up anything in WordPress because
it's it's under the associate programs
and then main so we don't have a program
called main so this should work and not
conflict so now that that's main we
should be able to get this and we're
going to need to make a new a new query
I wonder this probably way that we can
clean this up and not have so many
different queries as well but I'm gonna
wait and that can be a you know kind of
an optimization that we do later on if
we need to so for right now let's make a
new query new file and let's call this
associate
J s wonderful let's go to miner whoops
miner query and associate yes and now
let's just change things to associate
okay let's save that and let's also make
a page so this is just the component and
we'll take what we did here with minor
and let's put it here so we need to
change every instance of the word minor
and make it associate and let's make
sure we're getting our capitalization
correct all right so what will happen is
we go to the URL the ID part of the URL
will get passed into here and then that
will be available to pass on to the
query we'll get the data back the data
will be stored in props and then the
data will be used to render this
component if you want a more thorough
explanation of how that works you can
ask me in the live chat where you can go
back and re-watch some of the streams
that we did earlier on towards the
beginning of project five and I do go
you know in a lot more depth into you
know how this works alright so we need
to restart our server because we changed
some routes in our server j/s file and
after that starts up we will be able to
go to associate oops let's make sure I
did that right all right so we do have
associated we have this associate query
we have this let's see if I did this
rate on the server
you know let me see out what I I made
this in WordPress so I think it was more
than just associate so here's our custom
post type in WordPress and I believe I
made it associate program there we are
associate program so in our query we
need that look for Associates Program I
think like this I think that's it I
guess we can double check those
different entities all right well let's
give it a shot no programs
Hey
let's shake
I don't think I can use a hyphen here
now I can't
all right let's see
did I never restart my timer no I didn't
I'm just gonna keep an eye on the clock
some work on this for just another few
minutes and then I'll go back to the
live chat so it's saying cannot read
property edges of undefined so if we see
an hour component here see edges here
it's saying there is no data for
associate maybe that's because it's
supposed to be associates associate
program
there we are all right that was the
whole point so here's my problem so I
well two problems one I was trying to
get data under the name associate and
that's not the name that I had saved the
data under and I was trying to do that
in two different places so I just had to
change it in both places and now I could
get the data here's how it's coming in
for us so I'm not thrilled with how that
looks especially like the main headline
here is smaller than all the sub
headlines but I made it in at least
we're getting the data and it works and
it has no it has weird stuff like this
so the this is taking us to Maine dot
aspx admissions Maine dot aspx so I was
hoping that most of the links would work
but links that have dot aspx at the end
are obviously not going to work I didn't
realize that was the thing happening on
this site so definitely have to address
that that just might be that would be a
thing that either I can find like one
thing to go through the database and
remove that or maybe I can write
something that will remove it as we
import things or that'll just be
something that as we're testing a site
and as we go keep going through every
time we find it I just have to change it
or have someone else change it in
WordPress okay so the idea though is
that you have each of these and then a
page for each of these and when you
click the link it would take you to
associate slash and then let's say
theology and then that would show you
the Associates in theology page but
you're just a slash associate page would
have your list of everything and we're
going to do a similar thing for the
majors for the minors for departments
you know anything
that would make sense to have a list of
everything first which get any most of
the sections we're going to do it like
that okay looks good I'm gonna go back
to the live chat now and even though I
forgot the timer I think we're basically
staying on about the same timeframe that
we normally do so I'm going back to the
live chat right now I'm going to try to
answer all the questions that are in
there so if you have a question please
put it in there now and if you don't
want to stick around for the question
answer that's totally fine I'll see you
tomorrow if you can stick around though
I would appreciate your help in
answering the questions most of the time
you all have great answers much better
than than what I can come up with
Michael asks can you set up a database
with Department program degree site were
we at that point where we still talking
about routing just to be able to I guess
grab those or I mean I guess as possible
michael says you were one of the
students is going to have to hard-code
some stuff you're gonna have to deal
with it yeah I mean I yeah that's just
the way it's gonna be I mean eventually
mate who knows maybe after a couple of
years all the links will be or at least
most of the links will be switched over
to a more sane system but I I don't know
for right now we just got to cover it
and try to get as many links as possible
to work
michael says you really should only need
three queries Department program degree
type then branch out from there yeah I'm
wondering
I'm thinking about that there there's
there may def be a much better way to
handle this data it's not going to be
ideal I mean unfortunately I in
migrating the data it right now the data
is not organized in a way that makes it
easy to find stuff so that makes it kind
of difficult when I'm trying to bring it
over but then also I'm bringing it over
into WordPress I want it to be set up in
a way that it's like make some sense so
I'm making everything is custom post
types so that he's ever citing it can
quickly see like all okay it's the major
custom post type that's where I put
stuff for majors so I'm not sure how I
could set it up differently to follow
that hierarchy the other way potentially
could be set up a different server
graticule server that I don't know
organize things differently off to think
about that I mean right now I do have a
category I say the problem with the way
new things work with WordPress is like I
can't grab I don't think I can grab
multiple custom post types like with one
query
I'm gonna have to look into that I was
reading some issues on it on on github
anyway
I agree that this is not ideal this is
just kind of we're making it better than
it is now but it's not probably like the
most ideal way to organize everything
michael says i might not know much about
react WordPress or BJ's ninja but I do
know about databases I just think that
way alright that's cool I don't know a
lot about databases so any advice you
have for me in that area is definitely
welcome Michael's not sure why you are
so worried about major / minor I mean
I'm not it's not major minor in
particular it's just kind of in general
like the way things are happening with
the URLs when major and minor are also
happening I mean that's just kind of the
way things are across the the site so
it's not that major minor is so
important it's just that the way we're
gonna have to deal with this everywhere
is definitely important and I want to be
consistent so that's kind of why I'll
try I'm putting so much thought into it
now because whatever I decide we need to
use that going forward if I change my
mind later then I'll have to go back and
redo it so it's using a big deal except
that you know we need to get this
launched in like a month in February is
a short month so we're missing out on a
few days okay I've gotten to the bottom
of the live chat so I think pink
interrupts savage bananas says uqd Jesse
thank you I try I've been combing my
beard lately so I'm glad you noticed my
beauty so
alright so I'm going to get back to
bringing more data over and the more
data I bring over the better picture I
have of what we're dealing with so the
questions like how we're going to deal
with like moving you know how to deal
with URLs and organize things so I'll
have a better idea of what what we're
dealing with hubs savage furnaces
laughing so yeah deaths deaths out of
the beard that's all right I really
enjoy doing these last Jeff as you all
yeah so I should be back tomorrow
probably around the same time I don't
think I have anything conflicting on the
schedule and we'll be doing some of the
same work same work tomorrow so it's
going to be a lot of the same for a
little while
and then depending on how much data we
have moved over how much we get done
they maybe we can move on making it look
nice optimizing things refactoring and
testing lots of testing as much as we
can all right well I'll be back tomorrow
until then have a great day